i mean like i said uh i like we we we
we've thought about spoiler culture when
something as big as the avengers
um was you know aired into game of
thrones but that you could argue that
when it is such a big moment
in any media that obviously it deserves
to be talked about the moment it happens
that you're like oh my god please tell
me someone else has watched this this is
insane
i mean i i feel like this you know
hasn't caught up with
the culture right now because i could
understand that for example
when things were you know airing on tv
had one run of it and people would go
around the water cooler and discuss what
just happened but now
we're in a time when it's on demand
people watch things when they want to
and yet we still have the same like idea
around spoiling things as
as if people are watching things on tv
because i don't want to watch things as
soon as they yeah
i like pinching it that's just how i
should you should adapt the way that you
go this is why i miss this is why i miss
like dedicated forums
because with a dedicated forum on a show
right
you won't know anything about the spoils
of the show unless you decide to click
on the form
no because because the way the way to
adapt is just like i said
how do you solve this problem there is
no there is this there is never going to
go away
so why not just adapt to what's
happening because you can't change at
all because
i don't change with the time because i
don't want to [ __ ] wait an entire
week for the next episode i want to
binge it yeah
because like i hate watching the reason
i said it was because when
when when this idea came up for the
avengers everyone was like yes good
finally
someone said it i heard i saw people
spoiling it on twitter
yeah but probably not nearly as much as
without them no
the thing is i don't think it matters
like everyone got [ __ ] shamed for
doing it everyone was just like yo you
did a bad thing
don't don't [ __ ] do this yeah when
when we talk about tv shows and
especially now with attack when titan
it's just everyone's just doing it willy
nilly and the the
the mentality is well everyone's doing
it so i guess that's okay and that's
that's just
such a hard topic to discuss i wish i
had like more time to
prepare like an actual uh rebuttal but i
mean i i understand where you're coming
from
i just think that you know in the age
that we live in
you know now it's it's it's always gonna
be like that so why not just
adapt to what's happening yeah i mean i
like for me i grew up watching anime
manga
um i i mean i've gotten used to just
watching it in a bubble i like enjoying
like my entertainment in a bubble and
it's only recently that i've gotten
a different kind of enjoyment to see
like to discussing with friends and
everything like that
but when it's something that's um i mean
i mean in a perfect world right you'd go
in a coma yeah and you would wake up and
the doctor's like bro
here's your crunchyroll account his
attack on titan yeah don't get up yet
just pretend you're still asleep yeah
watch the rest of the episodes
yeah and then leave and then go on
twitter that's the perfect world right
where you can experience it full run
no breaks no weeks no [ __ ] on
twitter but that's just not how it works
yeah i know i know it's not how it works
i'm just what i'm all
i'm trying to argue is that why why is
it like this why why is it like
why do people not have a problem with
this i think because
i think people do have a problem with it
they just kind of like i think
especially in time i don't know anything
about it in times like now right where
everyone's also at home all the time you
know who you're going to talk to
your mom about a ton of titan no you're
gonna you're gonna go on twitter and
talk about with your friends because
everyone's at home do it yeah but like
but there's other venues to do that in
like isn't that the whole reason why
[ __ ] discord was invented
so you can create a private room where
you know the people you're discussing
there are some people
who you know to i you know not me
personally
yeah who you know they don't really talk
about stuff for their friends they just
like to
throw it into a void which is a case
right yeah but people like that need to
understand that no one gives a [ __ ]
about what you say
what i'm trying to say is if you want to
discuss it why why not discuss it on
like
the you know relevant subs stuff like
that you know probably where it belongs
yeah i mean
there's a difference between discussing
spoilers in a dedicated
here the episode here's the episode just
let's just go on a thread versus
let's just post screenshots and stuff
publicly on twitter that anyone it's the
whole assumption that
yes everybody who was a fan of attack on
time and anyone who would ever search
attack on titan
is searching it because they're watching
it weekly
and it's it's that it's that whole
misassumption where it's like and that's
why again like
if you want to discuss the [ __ ] you
know episode that just happened
do it on a private discord server do it
on the [ __ ] subreddit do it on a
[ __ ]
close all we need is spoiler etiquette
we need a system in place where
everyone's degrees
hey this is how you're gonna spoil it
yeah i mean that's that's that's that's
all i was talking about i i
i was talking about yeah i mean it's
never gonna happen
what i'm trying to say is it's never
gonna get to a point where everyone
follows this etiquette and everyone like
this is like a hard and fast rule that
everyone will follow no
all i'm saying is like why is there no
etiquency around this where people were
just like
this should be good it should be common
sense so there's and you know there's
all
also you're thinking to the fact that
okay 90 percent of people who are
posting stuff
yeah aren't intending it so they ruin
your day right but there's 10 of people
who are hoping that they get people to
who they spoil
yeah they get enjoyment knowing that
what i'm saying is like what it seemed
like around the avengers is that it was
that 10 of people
that the only spoilers you got were
people who are really looking to ruin
other people's day
right but at least we can we can all
point to them and say yeah they
they were an [ __ ] yeah yeah oh so you
wanted to become
more of a normalized [ __ ] thing too
yeah yeah
the fact that the fact that 90 of people
who are posting spoilers on twitter
about our talk on time aren't being
called out for it
i think it's the problem i i do think
it's
i mean because the anime is arguably
more popular i mean it is more popular
than the manga yeah right right i think
it's a little dickish people to post
panels from the manga when you can just
talk about them not post them to twitter
when you know
that the majority of people are anime
only right right that kind of annoys me
because that makes sense to me but even
still just just keep it privately
like yeah like i i get it posting the
anime because i'm like all right
everyone's watching the anime i found it
a real problem
where the last time i streamed literally
the first thing i had to say was
don't ask me questions about attack on
titan because the fact that
the fact that people will like type to
me in the chat
immediately like five minutes into me
streaming bank hey joe what do you
thought it was an attack on time
that happened i'm not gonna [ __ ] talk
about it because why would you assume
that i've caught up to it why would you
assume everyone in this chat is caught
up to it i'm not gonna do that so
to avoid spoilers let's just not [ __ ]
talk about it at all that's the best way
to do it
you want to talk about it do it in your
own [ __ ] i mean i mean like it's a
different conversation to say if
how much spoilers do you ruin a show or
ruin something i mean that's a different
conversation
i just that's a good conversation i i
just i just i just wish there was some
you know
basic etiquette i i you know what i was
mentioning earlier about the picture
that when you see a picture or frame or
a
you know an image from an anime you're
like oh man i wonder what wonder what
that's all about
yeah why is kaneki throwing his head
back why are you doing that yeah
um i i kind of think it's pretty cool
when you um
get when you have an idea of why this is
happening and then it's totally wrong
you're like oh that's how that happened
i thought this was gonna
i kind of like that that's kind of cool
not that i want please don't do this
but sometimes when it happens you don't
feel too spoiled and you're like yeah
but i feel
it's a bit of a different story with the
kaneki thing right because it's like
in the manga that's a really serious and
all i can imagine is you land
you know
it really does kind of like it's not so
much a spoiler it's just kind of like
the gap between what you expected and
what actually happened is like a
disappointment right yeah because i i
feel like it really much depends on the
show because like for example
i don't think it's physically possible
to spoil jojo
it's not you can post a panel you can
fully explain what's happening in the
scene and it won't prepare you for you
yeah yeah
exactly do i remember that time that
limp dick
fought biscuit soup and they kissed each
other to death and you're like oh is
that spoiler yeah i mean yeah
yeah yeah that is how the fight ends
yeah but you know it does like with
something like jojo it just it doesn't
hurt your enjoyment of the series
part of that is the enjoyment of the
series honestly it probably makes it
better if someone explains what's
happening
exactly and then you totally understand
but a character dying an attack on titan
anyone can understand that and it ruins
it yeah
it's it's a it's a minefield right now
um i just i just wanted to go on a quick
uh first world problem rant uh this this
is an this isn't actually an important
problem i just
i just wanted to go on another yeah i
mean spoiler culture's pretty fun to
talk about you know
discuss it what's going on